guys think there is a such thing as
female privilege
yes
yes i do what is female privilege um
[Music]
what is it
i think it's what like um like i feel
like actually
like pretty girls and stuff all do get
privileged and stuff
girl
okay next question next question why are
men taught how to treat women but women
aren't taught how to treat a man
no comments
like why are men taught how to treat
women but women aren't taught how to
treat a man so like from a young age we
always hear like this is how you treat a
woman but we never talk about how to
treat a man
well actually i never i think depending
on your like tradition as well like in a
black household you would usually be
taught okay you need to cook for your
mind you need to do this so i'd be like
like leader of the household type of
thing do you guys sue is that more
taught here because i'm from the us and
in the us that's not really talking
do you feel like in ireland like it's a
little bit more traditional here
um african cultures asian cultures
yeah yeah i agree with washington so did
you guys grow up in like an african
culture yeah i feel household yeah yeah
it's like the man is basically kind of
like the least
yeah the leader
the women still do like
work as well
yeah like don't get twisted
but like yeah we're the carers if you go
yeah basically okay um what are some
women's issues
they don't have any men is the problem
the video
wait what do you mean better matter of
the problem that are just the problems
they don't have to treat women in this
generation they don't know how to treat
women yeah they should be acting playing
okay my boyfriend is different he's not
included in the men why do you think men
don't know how to treat women like what
do they do wrong and i just feel like
they don't understand women to begin
with like yeah respect as well like
they're just rude yeah they just don't
have to like treat women how you're
supposed to treat women like you know do
you feel like women know how to treat
men though
yes
i feel like when a woman actually loves
like a man she knows how to treat him
well and same goes for men yeah
but it takes them a long time it takes
them a long time to fight they're bad
because they're slow in the head but
anyways so you guys said you said men
are trash did you say that before um do
you think it's okay since we could say
men are trash for men to say women are
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
that uh oh no women are only [ __ ] like
you know they only do them type of
things because men are the ones that
want it that's how we have prostitutes
because men actually pay women for sex
and also but you don't think that's like
kind of a double standard like the woman
has to agree to it
that's true but to be honest some people
need money they're kind of
um they have to do what they have to do
to get money so yeah but if a man needs
to do what he has to do to get money
like he's just homeless like women at
least have that option
i'm pretty sure because male prostitutes
though
do you think that's the exception or the
rule like come on
gay people they still meant prostitutes
right
are there any double standards in
relationships that don't favor women
relationships look what you mean
like like men pay for the dates like
women are kind of seen as the pride okay
no
no
but in this generation men and women
expecting people to also pay exactly
yeah first day
and everything sometimes they don't even
be expecting to split women you pay for
everything like bro yeah
do you guys wanna know an interesting
stat
so if you ask 20 of women what they want
in a guy or 80 percent of women what
they want in a guy they they list 20 of
men so the reason that women hate men is
because we're all sleeping with the same
ones
like the majority of men don't get any
women yeah yeah
does that surprise you or no
no
[Laughter]
no it doesn't surprise me
i'm surprised i was surprised when i got
that stat to be honest
basically men don't get women and women
speak with the same man over and over
again yeah so if you ask 80 of women to
list what they want and like their ideal
guy they list 20 of men and on dating
apps that's an even like smaller
percentage so the reason like women when
we say things like men are trash it's
because they're all sleeping with the
same guys but yeah thanks
so they don't see the nice ones and the
ones i actually treat so dude
do you think that's on women a little
bit because it's who we choose
well
okay that's actually true it does depend
on who you choose
but it's very hard to find a man that
that's actually like genuine and
dedicated because when they're not
genuine they are a vast thing it's like
they're actually breaks
do you think that's like the majority of
men though like don't you think that's a
small percentage of men that we're
attracted to that are the bastards
not because like actually not like every
boy i think of this actually
every boy i can't even say for these two
how old are you guys 18 18.
do they want you guys want to be in it
no